father liked him so did Loras Norris is young and
very good at knocking men off horses with a stick
that does not make him wise has your Fathead
father grandsons are think of us are you going
to bring the food or do you mean to starve us
to death the Lord of Highgarden I haven't had
the pleasure no great pleasure believe me
wondrous elf his father was an oaf as well
my husband the late Lord Luthor Joffrey I I you
you as this boy mistreated you as he ripped out
your tongue Jeff King Joffrey he bring me some
cheese the cheese will be served after the cakes
my lady the cheese will be served when I want
it served and I want you to serve now are you
frightened child another golden rose how original
I eat from plates stamped with roses I sleep in
sheets embroidered with roses I have a golden rose
painted on my chamber pot roses are boring dear so
might I said no you've taken an interest in Sansa
Stark am I why shouldn't I take an interest she's
an interesting girl is she no not particularly
gods boy that's enough we're not in a tavern but
no need to speak are there any FIGS fetch some I
had hoped we might discuss a few financial matters
I climbed all those steps to discuss financial
matters it's the royal wedding I was told you
were drunk impertinent and thoroughly divorced
you can imagine my disappointment at finding
nothing but a browbeaten bookkeeper where
did you go for them volantis your daughter
is rich the most beautiful woman in all Seven
Kingdoms and the mother of the King old old old
your grandfather gave me a necklace just like
this one my 51st nameday hmm the wedding is
in a fortnight grandmother you can't say no to
everything nonsense my little dears my lady my
lady aren't you just marvelous I hear you knocked
my grandson into the dirt like the silly little
boy he is you might find it suits you not now
mace I win and I is speaking there's nothing
more tedious than a trial except perhaps these
Gardens if I have to take one more leisurely
stroll through these Gardens I'll fling myself
from the cliffs you could smell the [__] from
five miles away put the pen down dear we both know
you're not writing anything oh yes the famously
talked on Queen of thorns and the famous topped
Queen sir see you there where would I find the
High Septon no high Sparrow or with a bloody fool
named he's got it's not as good a name as Queen
of Songs and admit you you should have the decency
to stand when you speak to a lady you should have
the decency to kneel before the gods don't spar
with me little fellow a man of the people who
does Circe's dirty work for her the people all
of us do the dirty work spare me the homilies I
can smell a fraud from a mile away the future of
house Tyrell don't pretend to have any concern for
my house my grandchildren or me and if I should
meet with some accident here at your broken little
flesh market they'll never even find what's left
of you you have been stripped of your dignity and
authority publicly shamed and confined to the red
keep what's left to work with you're not in your
sanctuary now my dear all I have to do is whistle
and my men will stroll in here and bash your
mother until I tell them to stop if I tell them
to stop you could use a good bashing grandmother
laura's rots in a cell because of you the highs
Pharaoh rules this city because of you are two
ancient houses face collapse because of you and
your stupidity we need each other I wonder feel
the worst person I've ever met but the truly vile
do stand out through the years Obara Obara you
look like an angry little boy don't presume to
tell me what I need forgive my sister what she
lacks in diplomacy do we shut up dear anything
from you no good let the grown women speak the
lords of westeros ha sheep you're a dragon be a
dragon that was Joffrey's sword wasn't it not that
he ever used it what has he called it widow's
wail he really was a [__] wasn't he I'd hate
to die like your son must have been horrible
for you not at all what I intended you see I'd
never seen the poison work before tell sathi
I wanted to know it was me [Music] you [Music]